president Trump is back in Washington
after a nine-day foreign trip he's now
dealing with provocative action from
North Korea and new drama in the Russia
investigation North Korea fired a new
anti-aircraft weapon system yesterday
and this morning it tested a short-range
missile and new reports over the weekend
focused on the president's son-in-law
and senior advisor Jared Kushner he
reportedly held meetings during the
presidential transition to set up a
secret communications channel with the
Kremlin in a tweet yesterday the
president claimed quote many of the
leaks coming out of the White House are
fabricated lies made up by the fake news
media Errol Barnett is in Washington
Eero good morning good morning
yes president Trump is standing by his
son-in-law in a statement to the New
York Times mr. Trump says he has total
confidence in Kushner and calls him a
very good person but the latest
revelations have some demanding
increased scrutiny for Kushner while
administration officials say these
allegations are being blown up out of
proportion I don't see any big issue
here relative to relative to Jared
secretary of homeland security John
Kelly sees senior adviser Jared
Kushner's alleged request to communicate
with the Russians as standard practice
anytime you can open lines of
communication with anyone whether
they're good friends or lots of good
friends is a smart thing to do sources
tell CBS News in December
Krishna met with Russian ambassador
Sergey kis lyac at Trump Tower according
to the Washington Post it was during
that meeting Kushner asked his lyac to
set up back-channel communications using
equipment at the Russian embassy which
would have carried security risks for
Moscow and the Trump team they are not
our friend former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper was unaware
of Krishna's request still Russian
interference was on his radar my
dashboard warning light was clearly on
and I think that was the case with all
of us and told us tonight the top
Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee believes Kushner's status is
in question I do think there ought to be
a review of his security clearance to
find
whether he was truthful whether he was
candid Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
is questioning the bat-channel request
which was reportedly revealed through
intercepted conversations between Chris
lyac and Moscow I think it makes no
sense that the Russian ambassador would
report back to Moscow in a channel that
he most likely knows we're monitoring
the whole storyline is suspicious now
while the president was overseas CBS
News has learned his team was working on
restructuring the White House
communications staff including setting
up a separate Rapid Response Team to
handle Russia investigation matters Dana
Errol thank you